[Musique]
la société chorale de saint lambert est
la plus gaie chorale au québec
elle célèbre son centième anniversaire
betty jo est la doyenne du groupe 44 1
mais c'est beaucoup
j'aime chanter les grandes oeuvres et
dans cet ouvrage nous avons eu beaucoup
d'opportunités de chanter les grandes
d'accord castrol si cette chorale a
traversé le temps c'est parce que ses
membres y vivent des moments uniques de
trouver l'harmonie comme ça c'était
quand même c'est comme une expérience de
la vie en sort et on est tellement
excité de qu'est ce qu'on a fait on peut
pas dormir apprennent qu'un pratique de
chorales
le chant choral compte cinq cent dix
mille adeptes au québec et on dénombre
3300 coeur un nombre qui ne cesse
d'augmenter
il ya un vrai essor et puis un vrai
renouveau de la pratique il ya dix
quinze ans les universités se sont mis à
créer des maîtrises en direction de
choeur et donc à toute une génération de
chefs de choeur qui sont arrivés sur le
sur le marché de la musique et les
bienfaits de la pratique sont bien
tangibles
louise drouin a fait des recherches sur
le sujet auprès de personnes plus âgées
les gens devenaient déclaré de votre
humeur il renaît c'est un peu parce
qu'ils arrivaient parfois vraiment
triste et il repartait au bout d'une
heure de chant avec des nouveaux amis un
deux trois
les plus jeunes aiment aussi joindre
leurs voix à celles des autres au québec
deux cent dix mille enfants chantent en
choeur
[Musique]
une des raisons est c'est de pouvoir
chanter avec des personnes que j'aime
bien avec qui je m'entends et tout ça
crée un sentiment d'appartenance et art
en groupes et à l'école
donc c'est un peu comme faire partie
d'une équipe de sport au niveau culturel
[Musique]
et pour andré une vent la chorale est un
moment privilégié qui ne veut surtout
pas manquer je suis vraiment excité gens
parlent tout le temps mes parents puis
dès que ça arrive je ne change pas
rapidement
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
à